or some other shows that you like then
i feel like um
i i had a shonen phase
everyone that and everyone else in the
world i see you were once 14 years old
i loved hunter hunter
yes because that [ __ ] was just it was
just great where are you cool
to alchemist long and you finish on the
hunter
name another show where you cry over an
octopus yeah in one piece yeah you cry
of an octopus in one piece yeah cry over
a lot in one piece yeah there's a lot of
things you cry over
okay well i gotta get them
i think uh i think for me it's like
they just they they've mastered the
formula in every shonen it's like they
know the exact moment to play the exact
song that's like the perfect song
whether it's like the naruto theme or
it's like the you say run yeah and it's
like the climactic and they just have it
it's like it will never surprise me ever
it's basically the hero's journey retold
a million times yeah but they're good at
it they're very good at it but you know
one thing i miss i've noticed like a lot
of shonen shows are just anime shows
i've been doing this less often recently
which is you know it's the end of the
season and then they play the eop and i
i've noticed they stopped doing that and
it was just like yeah it became a trope
but it worked every [ __ ] time right
like where it's like they and they lift
off in a sunset and then you know season
two is coming or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm just like i wish they
brought that back
the 80s freeze frame right yeah it is
it's that yeah i think it's a bit corny
and what happens is it it's too corny
and then it goes out of style and then
it comes back in right yeah yeah
cycles yeah because like i remember
because hunter hunter had like the same
op throughout it's every season that
gets me hyped there you go he got you so
hyped now and and now every different
season has a different opening i'm like
come on bring back hunter hunter man
that yeah that note only needed one
opening departure
isn't it crazy because like attack on
titan has like 10 openings yeah that's
[ __ ] they're good
rumbling is awesome
i like that they try new ones because i
feel like they come out with some
bangers well i feel like i feel like
attack on titan i can understand it
because every season has such a
different vibe to it like season one and
season four have like nothing in common
with it but you know
i the one thing i do like about it when
they have the same opening is that it's
you recognize it so much familiarity
you play an op and you're like i don't
know i don't know what this is it's like
oh it's attack on titan season three uh
opening one you're like what the [ __ ] i
had no [ __ ] idea i i like listened to
this i i have that problem watching
guinta because there's like literally 20
openings in game time i'm like they're
all bangers but it's like you know you
want that one where you just like oh
yeah i remember that but imagine naruto
only had one they have the best interest
there's so many i guess sorry goated
interest that's true that's true but
like how many do you remember out of
like the millions that they've had i
only remember hanukkah the second one
which is like arguably the best one i
think i remember the third one three
blueberries did you ever watch uh
atari series you'd love that shirt would
he i don't know i think so
he he likes nhk no he would not he'd get
to the toothbrush scene he'd be like
what the [ __ ] is this
out-of-pocket [ __ ] yeah
what happens
it's some horny [ __ ] tell me what
happens
in your voice though
slowly
there was a there was just so
it's a [ __ ] weird show if if if you
thought the uh
the wait what was the first show you
watched it online with the guy
holding onto the girl was a [ __ ]
weird you're probably even more weirded
out by the stuff i mean that was early
on like yeah there's weirder [ __ ] and
like eventually what happens it's like
it's like when you're a kid and you see
live league footage you become
desensitized to the internet anime fans
become desensitized to like what is
weird there's a very famous scene where
the guy's sister yep yep sister yeah
it's brushing his teeth and it's like
animated like porn and it's they're all
like moaning and [ __ ] and like oh while
brushing yeah like what is the brushing
so good yeah so like food wars eating
there's like no brushing honestly like
it's [ __ ] awesome honestly i i'm
gonna defend this because it's a really
really really really really really
really
really
really
really
really really really really really really weird
because she's because she would because
it's a brother and sister of course no
no okay
genuinely genuine brothers should be
allowed to [ __ ] sisters
genuinely i i wish i wish hentai was
this well directed it's such a well
[ __ ] directed scene to be like okay
how can we make tooth brushing really
uncomfortable and really weird and yeah
it's [ __ ] weird and it's horny as
[ __ ] but like is that what opened like
your chakras to brother sister kind of i
don't think i i know that was sorry that
was oriental but you must have watched
back when i got through first right i
watched batman guthrie first but it's
not even in bhagavad-gita it's in season
two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i don't
know like welcome to guthrie was just
it's a weird show in general it's got
like very weird like directing choices
it's one of my favorites really yeah
yeah it's like it's it's a joey show
because it's [ __ ] like it's arthousy
it's like it's like nothing [ __ ]
makes sense and then everyone's like
that's the point and it's like yeah
do you think end of evangelion's like
that
ah that's like way too mainstream now i
think oh no but it also doesn't make
that much [ __ ] sense no
i i'm i think evangelion is kind of mid
uh i think it's kind of way over hyped
and it was just like it just happened to
be there the right time so it kind of
caught massive popularity because of
that yeah i really get high so people
think i'm cool and it was doing
something just doing something unique
yeah no [ __ ] but i'm not even
entertaining that call it it's not true
i do that yeah i was like yeah i love
that show that was great but i when i
think back on it i was like i don't like
it like we should have it like did you
watch evangelion were you like this is
insane i was just kind of like okay i
mean i think i don't know if it's
because i've watched shows that have
come out after but maybe if i was there
at the time i could see why it would
blow the [ __ ] up and be such a big deal
but now it doesn't feel that special
yeah i mean ava for me like ava's like
one of my favorite shows of all time i
[ __ ] hated it the first time i
watched it yeah like i i legitimately i
legitimately thought it was like the
most overrated piece of [ __ ] i'd ever
seen in my life and it was just i don't
know it's it's very it's it is a
pretentious show it's it's a [ __ ]
pretentious show because i only liked it
because i was [ __ ] depressed one time
i watched it and i'm like [ __ ] hell
there's someone who gets me because
that's that's just that's just
just like me for real yeah yeah that's
just like the whole struggling with
relationships and uh growing up and
struggling being a teen i yeah i just
like cause i watched brocarano before it
i thought boca rano handled it like way
better yeah but i'm sure poker hunter
took notes from evangelion yeah there
did yeah but like because the mech
fighting in book riot was dog [ __ ] some
guy they're in a cave when there's like
10 of them on a school trip he's like
hey you want to play a game
and then they got they're like the kids
are like well [ __ ] you i want to play a
game
and so he's like oh
go on this thing and then he teleports
them to a mac and then he's like all
right who wants to pilot the mac first
and then some kid's like yo [ __ ] you i
want to power up the mac kid parts the
mech and he's like right now there's
another mac that is invading your world
if you don't kill this mech your world
gets destroyed and everyone's like oh
okay so then the kid takes it beats the
mech and i was like yeah and the episode
ends and the kid just dies
why because anyone who's a one-time use
yeah and you want to pilots
and it's all like 12 13 year old 16 year
old kids and is using him as fodder yep
so it's like a darker ender's game yeah
but it's like it's not it's like
it's not like it's kind of like a horror
thing where it's like whoa it's like a
death game it's like they have to save
the world and they have to die to do it
it's like a psychology but they don't
know they all know wait they didn't know
though they didn't know initially and
they see the kid they didn't know until
the first kid died and then and then
someone and then the guy was like oh
[ __ ] what happened to the kid
yeah
oh that wasn't supposed to happen
like these kids i guess it's gonna
happen forever though basically it's
already running it's already right they
don't know who's uh who's turn's next um
so all the kids are just kind of like
and you don't know when you're gonna get
summoned right so all the kids are just
kind of dealing with their mortality do
they know they're gonna win uh they
don't know they're gonna win
like that would be the more stressful
yeah
i feel like this was pretty
irresponsible
of course it is but it's an amazing
thing you should train the kids a little
more and some of the kids deal with like
this whole mortality and having to pile
up this mac and it's so nuanced it's so
good this is the opening
such a good opening and like i just felt
like it it offered so much more in that
like kind of dealing with it and it
hadn't in my mind i felt like it did it
better than evangelion no because like i
i think i think it's entirely different
from what i felt from ava right because
eve like i look at boca rano i'm like
this is a really really good exploration
into like characters and how they deal
with mortality and all that [ __ ] but
then like you look at the last two
episodes of ava and it's just like it's
just a [ __ ] person laying themselves
bare they don't even give a [ __ ] if
they're making sense because it's making
no [ __ ] sense at all but like if
you've been in that same headspace
there's like a connection there that is
hard to communicate because it's not
really telling a story it's just a guy
just being like i'm [ __ ] depressed
and i just want to put something out
it's just like an overflow of emotion
yeah yeah that's what that's what i
think is unique about ava where i don't
even think like if you say ava's a [ __ ]
story i'm gonna agree with you it's it's
it's that there are like so many [ __ ]
plot holes and [ __ ] that doesn't get
explained i'm not saying it's bad it's
just i i i don't think it's as uh good
as it's hyped up to be i don't know yeah
that's easy to say yeah only bold takes
here
this this thing actually might not be
that good well you know like you know
not not everything that is extremely
influential is necessarily
true
i mean jojo has a lot of dog [ __ ] stuff
in it like it's a i love jojo did that
you just don't get that
like legit just don't
there's also a lot of influential [ __ ]
that you can understand and believe
that's influential but you don't care
about oh yeah like movies like i've
never seen citizen kane it seems boring
as hell
you kidding me pretty slow three hours
a lot of filler man i filmed a film was
like three and a half hours or some [ __ ]
bruh got some of that damage is like the
[ __ ] schneider cup that's crazy right
any controversial or uh un you know
unpopular opinions of anime i you got
mad at me five seconds ago
yeah i you okay do you do this this is a
a quick aside okay but okay i will i
will consume an anime yeah yeah and
depending on if it's a good ending i
will feel emotion and i'll mull over the
thoughts for like a day yeah yeah and
then the next day i'm like googling like
okay what do people think about the show
do people like the show
and like i'll look up all that [ __ ] and
then i'll like add outside knowledge my
own thoughts and i'll try to form my
opinion on it is that how you guys do it
or do you just have your own thoughts i
used to
do that and then i had to stop myself so
now when i watch things i do not look at
reviews before
before and after really i don't want to
know sometimes i'll go i'll have a look
and i'm curious because i'll be like um
because sometimes it's always when i
think something is bad but i'm not sure
i'm like this is bad i think and i feel
like people might like it so i go and
look just to confirm but i don't read
reviews i never read reviews do you do
you think that's because it'll like
sully what your thought of it is
definitely i feel like there's
you know when you watch this like
explainer videos and they explain more
of the thing to you and you're like oh
that's so big brain like i i watch dune
and i love dune but when i watched a
bunch of explainer videos i was like oh
i think i like dune more yeah then i'm
like i've watched an hour and a half
video about dude and i'm like is that
i'm like is that do i need that to enjoy
it like if i didn't watch that would i
like dune as much and it's kind of like
this weird thing of like how much do you
actually enjoy something if you
everything has to be explained to you
and bogged down and reviews have to be
explained to you and well maybe it's not
necessarily like new information there
but rather something that maybe you
thought subconsciously which is now
actually being said to you to make you
realize like oh okay i always thought
maybe that element might have been good
but now that i'm keep getting explained
yeah now i can confirm my suspicions
yeah i mean like i find you know as the
guy who finished like all the [ __ ]
sword art online yeah you know i've
gotten to a point with anime where you
you watch you watch anime and you look
you you see the good [ __ ] and you're
like damn that's the good [ __ ] you know
i want to find more of that and then you
kind of realize that you have taste
right and so you have
things that you like about shows and
things that you don't like about shows
and just because some of the elements
about why people are playing uh praising
a show in like all the good shows are
presents
that maybe still doesn't appeal to you
so you you kind of like you kind of like
shave off all the all the fat to
only like the core elements that you do
like you know even that even if that's a
very very niche thing um so you get to a
point where i can tell why i like a show
even if other people won't like that
show like i can say why i would like
watched all the sword art online even
though a lot of people clown and sword
art online no i can i can you recognize
the [ __ ] things about the show and you
just kind of learn to ignore it at the
end of the day i like doing it because
it it kind of feels to me like like you
can enjoy a sports game yeah like you
can watch basketball you'd be like oh
dunk is cool he jumped high yeah but if
you are sitting next to michael jordan
while watching the game like his level
of insight would be like okay you are
you are not seeing the things the way
i'm seeing them yeah yeah and i i know
that my lens is probably like very
narrow in what i'm seeing and that goes
for like shows movies whatever
so that's why i like to like i watched
tom popo i think i told you guys about
which is like the japanese 80s movie
yeah um and you know i was like this
movie is the only movie made in the 80s
yeah only the only
japanese or whatever
no other movies
somewhere else there was a recession
sri lanka was going through it
when is this for like a going through
that's true i'm gonna oh
yeah but i was watching it and and i was
like okay i left and i was like i
thought this was a good movie i liked it
but then i like i looked up like little
things about it and it's like yeah it
was actually also a direct contrast to
like western american movies and like
old-fashioned spaghetti westerns and it
was like they called it like a like a
ramen western i was like oh [ __ ] and
then like i could think about it in that
lens and i feel like if i were to
rewatch it i would like have new
appreciation yeah i mean i feel like
stuff like that where you discover
things that you can make that make you
appreciate a certain show more yeah that
that happens like a lot actually but
like in terms of like reading thinking a
show is good and reading reviews and
you're just like my opinion was wrong
this show is actually bad you know i
love it when there's like you know you
you can re-watch a movie and there's
those really cool things that you missed
yeah i but i still think and fully
believe that a a movie or a tv show on
your first watch should still have
everything for you that you can enjoy
yeah if it doesn't do that it requires
someone to sit you down and be like no
no cause let me explain this to you let
me explain and i'm like then it's failed
yeah but if i can go back and do the
second time and watch it and i can
appreciate all that amazing yeah like
the only time it ever really happens to
me where i change my opinion instantly
is only like when i'm [ __ ] watching
like masterchef or something you know
where they bring out a dish i'm like
that dish looks delicious and then
gordon says it's disgusting
yeah
when they bring out too much food and
i'm like [ __ ] yeah that's so much bang
for your buck he's like why is there so
much food it's disgusting oh god
yeah [ __ ] up